das ist paradiesisch
das ist natur pur
mit einer waage
[Musik]
wenn die folgenden 22 minuten ein wenig
auch wie eine erste august ansprache
tönen dann hat es damit zu tun dass es
sich beim porträtierten um adolf ogi
handelt und doch muss ich gestehen ich
habe nicht ungern zugehört
[Musik]
alt bundesrat adolf ogi wird 70 eine
kunst ist das nicht denn das war dem
massaker folgt meist erst später doch 70
jahre das ist ein gutes alter durchs
land zu reisen und ein wenig zu
resümieren etwa zu fragen was in diesen
unsicheren zeiten aus dem eben zu
berühmten wie belächelten op optimismus
geworden ist
nach seinen zwölf jahren als bundesrat
mit trat adolf ogi die weltbühne die
wurde uno sonderberater für sport und
war somit direkter mitarbeiter von
generalsekretär kofi annan seine aufgabe
war keine geringere als mit den mitteln
des sports die entwicklung und den
frieden zu fördern
zur gleichen zeit war auch ein anderer
schweizer politiker global unterwegs
nicht auf den sportplätzen sondern
beiden hungerleidenden der welt jean
ziegler damals uno
sonderberichterstatter für das recht auf
nahrung
die und ziegler beide stammen aus dem
berner oberland doch damit erschöpfen
sich die gemeinsamkeiten
ihr der marxistische professor mitglied
der sp dort der bürgerliche
nichtakademiker immer noch der svp
angehörige entfernt können welt nicht
sein ich habe schon viele zu adolf ogi
befragt und bekam erstaunliches zu hören
ein staatsmann einer von der ganz wenige
staatsmänner oder stars frauen was die
letzten 50 jahre in der schweiz ziemlich
außergewöhnliche figur national oder
international was sie bei ihm
unglaublich schätze ich die
über zügig auf die energie- und frauen
die menschliche wärme im jahre 1987
wurde der svp nationalrat in den
bundesrat gewählt
bobbycar massensport und wurde lange
zeit unterschätzt für zu leicht befunden
doch man muss feststellen wo sie hat
mehr erreicht als viele andere hoch
gelobte bundesräte zu aus dem verkehrs
und energie der partyband dann im vbs
aufgewachsen war oben kann das steak wo
sein vater bergführer und
gemeindepräsident war
stolz führt der staatsgäste wie den
französischen präsidenten mitterrand in
seine heimat und mit der zähigkeit des
berges verfolgte adolf ogi auch seine
ziele das meisterstück war gewiss die
nähert
2010 konnte er zusammen mit
amtsnachfolger moritz leuenberger denn
durch staus am gotthard feiern
[Applaus]
so ist es auch kein zufall dass er an
diesem frühlingstag zur
jahresversammlung der tunnelbau in
sursee geladen ist ihr erklärter mit
unverhohlenem stolz wir die
eu-verkehrsminister von der nähert
überzeugte denn diese wollten lieber
eine achtspurige autobahn durch den
gotthard was eine eisenbahn
ich habe viele briefe
geringschätzung gewohnt griff zu
drastischen methoden er lud die
verkehrsminister zu einzel abreibungen
ins urner reusstal wurde ihnen die
topographischen zwänge für abend führte
und bei besonders begriffsstutzigen
amtskollegen mit dem belgischen
verkehrsminister jean luc dehaene kam
sogar ein folter ähnliches prozedere zur
anwendung
felswand
haben angehalten ich habe den
sicherheitsgurt von jean luc dehaene
gelockert ich habe den leuten gesagt
dass pc markt
und dann habe ich soeben gesagt charlie
gysi und bei wem apa kanzlerin oder rot
er ist auf meinem knie gesprungen und
gästeservice
ölpapiere ich weiß meine damen und
herren das ist nicht diplomatisch das
ist auch nicht akademisch aber das ist
wirkungsvoll
[Applaus]
dies hier ist nicht wahlkampf sondern
einfach adolf ogi
jedem der 90 tunnelbauer schüttelte alt
bundesrat zum abschied die hand es ist
schon so wenn man mit adolf ogi durchs
land reist dann wird einige zeit fürs
handy schützen verwendet ist wurde meist
gerührte politiker der schweiz auch
zwölf jahre nach seinem abschied aus dem
bundesrat ist er immer noch ungemein
populär
[Musik]
im jahre 1992 allerdings wieder für ihn
ungewohntes schmerzhaftes in der
schweizer schreihälse beschimpften den
patrioten als landesverräter damals als
er sich für europa für die wehr
aussprach
europa und die schweiz eine irgendwie
verkäufer die beziehung ist es bis heute
geblieben und das schmerzt nicht zuletzt
adolf ogi
sondern mit sprach mit gestaltet ich
habe die position beschriebene
gemäßigten
europa blieb die schweizer
frauen
ist doch dass wir nach
der eu betreibt und das bedeutet nicht
weh das zeitfenster zur
aber das hier ist das muss ich mir
gedanken mache ich hatte sie
214 ausgesehen da sich auch das was die
politik muss keiner der politiker muss
nicht das hat die politik muss überlegen
mit 26 30 40 jahre und wenn da müssen
wir alternativen entwickeln
alternative nicht prinz ich bleibe
das ist eh variante aber eine andere
variante jährigen eröffnet
und zwar aus vorbereitet bevor das müsse
machen dass bezwungen hatte das ich
schick die
intelligente weise politik ich hoffe ich
habe noch eine chance das revers
verdient unsere unterstützung verdient
auch die unterstützung der svp europa ag
und die svp schon vor 20 jahren hat er
es der unverwüstliche optimist versucht
vergebens eiskalte ablehnung waren
europa und oki gewiss
hugo boss heißen die einstigen
persönlichen mitarbeiter des damaligen
bundesrates alle jahre treffen sie sich
heuer bewegt sich die wandergruppe durch
die hügel oberhalb von board
mitglied der ogi boys ist auch eine frau
sonja bietenhard damals svp heute bdp
sie muss die jeweils zwischen obi unter
partei vermitteln
hat ob es eu haltung in der partei nicht
isoliert
christoph blocher
die hessen schmidt mit war toll
verstanden
und das ist eben hätte mir kraft
getragen und senior vorstellung
reise an den rand der schweiz
ist von schorsch pro jahr denn direkt
oder jurassischen bahnen zu einem besuch
eingeladen worden ein jahr hat er unter
okay im bundesamt für verkehr gearbeitet
erneut erstaunt das große interesse am
einstigen werner bundesrat gerade hier
in deutschland
mehrere journalisten möchten mit oki
sprechen
woher rührt diese anhaltende popularität
an einem 70 jährigen politiker im
ruhestand
ist
verständlich wirst du von der politik
vertraue ich gehörte kapital
verspielt
denn es ist schwierig die direkte
demokratie
und
menschenrechten auf welche fehler
gemacht aber ich spürte aber nicht
wählen also an verwalten sondern hat das
land wieder gestalten
die hat er als verkehrsminister stets
wert darauf gelegt dass auch die
peripheren gegen in der schweiz ans land
angebunden bleiben selbst wenn das etwas
kostet man könnte dies aus pflege des
gemeinsinns bezeichnen
uns flehte sie wenn sie sowohl als ist
gleich behandelt werden
denn geht es weg eltern geht spanischer
jahres ein land
das nach wie vor
investitionsplans ökonomischer alle drei
der fünf und acht ökonomisch lohnt sich
also der ökonom tür mit garantie dass
mehr
zukunft
in frieden und freiheit aber dass manche
politiker machen die sensibilität mit
dem gespür für das was nötig ist
und für das was
realistisch ist das heißt dass nicht
topmodernen sie wir vielleicht den
bahnhof zürich aber es muss es muss
aufpassen dass die er sich nicht
vernachlässigt fühlen
an diesem abend ist adolf ogi unterwegs
richtung magglingen
dort im bundeseigenen sportzentrum ist
der einstige sportminister an einem
kongress geladen im schatten der sport
wirtschaft heißt das thema es geht um
korruption doping wettbetrug und ein
wenig erinnerte daran dass der sport
half seine karriere schatten geworfen
hatte
es war 1999 und das rad obi hatte sich
mit ganzer kraft und dem prestige wie
eine olympia kandidatur von zion
verwendet doch ioc-chef samaranch
verkündete turin als gewinnerin und ogi
der fast nur das siegen kannte erdgas
verliert in die schweiz zurück das ist
eine niederlage nicht nur für sich
sondern für die schweiz mit dem sieg
setzt mit das stets besser tastet die
beste präsentation
etwas weiter es ist ungerecht empfunden
weil auch nach der wahl kriegen einen
ort gesucht für die olympischen spiele
für die politik kommt noch ein zweiter
wagen einen ort gesucht dass es weiter
geht die olympische bewegung ist
gelungen ja das war samaranch das
problem acoustics das problem mit der
visa sich das problem mit der stelle
sich das problem mit mit mit buchprojekt
hätten frauen mehr aufblüht und
sportminister funktioniert das problem
mit probiert's löse nicht das
versprochene spieler versammeln und wir
sind das etwa
zwei jahre später folgte eine weitere
persönliche niederlage denn nach seiner
bundesrats zeit gerne ins olympische
komitee gewechselt hätte wurde nicht
gewählt nicht mal die schweizer ioc
mitglieder darunter fifa-chef sepp
blatter hatten sich für die verwendet
[Musik]
auch denke
da müssen wir jetzt vielleicht
doch schnell hält sich rubys gemüt
wieder auf
kann das steak wo adolf ogi herkommt und
wo er zusammen mit seiner frau immer
noch einen teil des jahres lebt
hier gibt es eine adolf ogi straße
gleich neben dem schulhaus
das ist die universität das ist schon
ein universitäts gegangen ist weniger
betrieb mehrere
massengräber worten ich hätte mir gesagt
hat mir daraufhin der
stellvertreter hat mich seit die
bundesrat rate wünsche mir natürlich
dass du intelligent ist aber sollte
weiter wünschen die frauen weisheit oder
einfache wahl geführt haben der stadt
mit runter schiedsrichter intelligenz
und drei seiten und hinten wo das tal
endet verschwindet die bahn im
lötschberg tunnel wird am neujahrstag
2000 zu bedeutungsvollen tv kulisse
wurde
[Musik]
mit jenen die zu packen
die folge die herz haben und die träumen
können live sex ist die schweiz lebt
sowohl ubs pressesprecher was auf der
chefredaktor des schweizer fernsehens
riten damals auf die ausstrahlung dieser
ansprache zu verzichten doch blieb hart
und lieferte damit die wohl einzige
neujahrsansprache an die sich das
publikum auch nach jahren noch erinnern
kann
[Musik]
we had natur optimismus der zuversicht
oder aber vorgezeigte siegburg
felix esch naiv
so permanent optimistisch amira hass
nicht erfunden aber sie ihren etat
gesteckt mit dem atheismus
maxisch kiwi weiß dass die man situation
von menschen
überhaupt versteht aber der optimismus
von mattel foto das wird die schon
richtig sei dass also
richtlinie aus naivität
münchen/planegg
optimistische heutige tag probe
immer realist liebe august was wir
können und die hoffentlich ist was man
nicht können und darum billionen
committee der hochtrabenden
gedanken und träumereien sondern heimat
probiert mit bdo von borders bliebe
ver.di bis muss sind sie haben sagte
belächelt wurde damals ja das ist doch
naiv dass prof
frage ich die sachen die erlebt wo
damals
nun also wird adolf ogi 70 jahre alt
sein freund schon ziegler der
marxistische professor aus genf hat
diese schwelle schon geschafft
also ich sage das
japanische
angst vor
situationskomik sie war immer so blöd
sind was ist schon weiß das ist schon
weiß dass rupert kämpfen und wenn sich
ein ausnahmeverfahren
für das bankrotte weise und durch
dort kann
das ist unnützer mensch
der junge adolf ogi ehemann und vater
von zwei kindern
dass sein sohn matthias 2009 36 jährige
an krebs starb dies ist die große
persönliche tragödie des kandersteger
cent kommt
ich hatte mein sohn und ich bin bereit
halte zu akzeptieren und die bereits
akzeptiert es ist uns wichtig es ist
realität und dem man sagen september
also klebt die
solar verloren
das bei mir noch stärker vorhanden
apa red
die spread also
ich habe
vergangenes
im historischen gasthof niehues in
kandersteg hört sich auf uschi glas
worte an
wie ist das möglich eine solche
zuneigung über die enorme politische
spannweite hinweg was able mail das
berührt mich
dass sie habe über party grenze
denke dass er die partie glänzer
respektiere und ich glaube das ist sehr
wichtig meint steht im vordergrund
der politischen auseinandersetzung
so sprach der eigene partner ebene
sondern linken max ist diese
wurde das maxxi stellt oder andere krise
aber sie sagen eigentlich der mensch im
mittelpunkt und schauen sie edelmetall
machen und schipper waldmann wurde
profil kurz dar
menges auf sogenannt das früher waren
eine sache treppe wo man damals
kritisierte
tauss als verwerflich betrachtet hält
und hält
alles falsch gesehen
adolf ogi berger nicht akademiker
svp-bundesrat und doch stand diese
biografie seine offenheit nie im wege
die öffnung zu anders denken der zu
anderen sprache zu anderen kulturen
das interessiert da ich sehe das was
sieht aus verlegt werde dir also die
weltoffenheit wo sie zeigen dass berger
die 100 liefert ihre herkunft oben die
hat fehlt für
metall eröffnet
wenn ich öffentlich sage ich es öffnet
vom zog musik oder zog von bundes- sie
mit gewalt mit ihrer mächtigen
und in paris stiegen umstieg
[Musik]